[Applause]
first up we have ty rushing from
nashville tennessee hello ty what is
your question hi drew hi gracel
here's my question
so i've always been told men enjoy the
chase so i shouldn't be to want the one
to chase him
nowadays i feel like women go for what
they want
i don't want to be too assertive
so any advice on how to make a subtle
advance garcelle thoughts i would say um
if you don't want to make the first move
i do think men do love the chase but you
also have to give them a sign that you
like them whether it's a smile longer
eye contact you know saying hi
i think that's okay i think they have to
know that you're interested so
dangle a little carrot the hanky yeah in
a jane austen novel yes and you drop it
and you drop it oh did i drop no
no i think you have to give him a sign
but i also feel like we do live in a new
normalized modern society where you can
go up to a guy and say
would you like to go to dinner would you
like to have coffee ty would that ever
work for you
i could try it i would definitely try it
i would definitely try it i think that
could work for me i like it dude all
right thanks for asking hi good luck
totally
all right mike draper
what is your question uh yes i'm a
single dad i'm in the dating scene and
so my issue is more
uh when i love i love hard right and so
when i make that kind of commitment to
somebody where i'm like after how many
ever dates and i'm like okay i like this
person like my mind goes zero to 100 and
my heart goes zero to 100 right and so
how do i slow that down
and how do i still stay open to that
person without going full speed ahead
with life
i get it i'm like that too when i love i
love hard
um how old are your kids if i can ask i
have one seven-year-old daughter um i
would say
take your time what's the rush do you
want to get married again
i'm in no rush no but no right now
no not in rush i say take your time i
mean you can do all the sweet things
that i it sounds like you would do
but don't go like you know don't go ring
shopping
no i'm not i'm not overbearing like no i
just really slow down a little i mean
slow yourself down she doesn't need to
know that you're doing that but i just
you know don't call as much let her like
i think this mystery is nice and when
there's a kid involved you already have
exact boundaries built in of how slow or
fast you can take it agree because no
revolving door of dating for children
it's not healthy
so
protect her protect yourself
also you're raising a daughter
yeah
what would you tell your daughter
you know
i would think you'd want to give your
daughter advice about not moving too
fast you know and and seeing if this
truly is your person all right thank you
mike i look forward to hearing how this
all goes
um okay next is sarah chen
where are you sarah
hey so i have a question about paying
the dreaded question
so do you think that the girl should
expect the guy to pay for the first few
dates or do you think we need to be a
bit more lenient nowadays
i go back and forth on this because one
i truly believe like a man should pay
for the first meal absolutely but i'm
also raising boys and i don't want them
to be taken advantage of all the time so
i don't have a problem paying for like
maybe the third or fourth date saying i
have this but i think the first one he
should pay i really do what would you
prefer for yourself may i ask i mean
honestly i want them to pay for the
first few dates i've gone on dates
before where like i'll always do the ask
of like oh like i'll also do half seas
with you and i work in the corporate
world and stuff i know i know i probably
shouldn't
you say okay half not right not right
away
i mean if we want to be courted if we
want to be treated
like a lady
i think they really should pay but
there's other things you can do if
you're at the valet now i mean i live in
l.a so there's a lot of valet i know new
york you don't but if you you can say oh
i'll get the valet for you do you know
what i mean i think there's different
little things you can do yeah if you're
going to cohabitate you're going to have
to split eventually right going dutch on
the first date isn't as sexy yeah there
but it's nice that you offer but it does
leave a door open so maybe figure out
what you want but trust you're a
well-intended person wants to offer it's
confusing it's not it's not it's not
obvious well let's just keep talking
about love together it's so loud any
time
of me as i am it is available now
garcia's beautiful new network
[Music]
you